Please MatPat, do a theory on shorts wars.
MatPat needs to take a look at the YouTube
shorts ARG.
There is now a ARG in...
This might be part of a well known...
Shorts wars...
(kerfuffle of voices)
Okay, okay, I get it.
We're doing the shorts war.
Wait, it just ended?
Dammit.
Hello Internet!
Welcome to Film Film Film Theory Theory.
The show that just wants you to sub
sub sub sub sub sub subscribe.
Hmm, strange.
The overwhelming glitchy-ness seems to
indicate that we're covering an ARG today.
And not just any ARG.
This one is found right here
on the shores of YouTube.com.
Specifically,
we're talking about the Shorts Wars,
an ARG staring a variety of different
shorts-centric channels; including Bundun,
Danno Cal Drawings,
Joe Caine, RoyalPear, Phaleur,
and the biggest of them all,
at least according
to subscribership, Jonny RaZeR. Now,
if you're not familiar with the last one,
it's likely that you're familiar
with the fallout of his work.
Remember a few months ago,
when everyone suddenly
became very invested in the Waffle House
finding itself a new host?
Well, that was the brainchild of Mr.
Bad Ideas, Jonny RaZeR himself.
And now he and that crew of other creators
are at it again.
Or not really them.
Rather, it's an army of clones
replacing them.
Regardless, they're up to some new tricks,
and it's up to us to figure
out what's going on.
Like I
was saying, it's up to us to come around
a bit later in the process to recap
what happened, put the pieces together,
and THEN solve what's going on.
*whispering* Thanks, guys
for recognizing that daily
lore drops are really hard
for us to cover in real time.
Now if all of this is new to you,
then I recommend
you go to check out their channels, links
for all of them are down there
in the description below.
Because what this group has created over
the past month is one of the most fun
uses of YouTube that I've seen happen
in a long, long time.
This thing spans over 100 shorts, live
streams, multiple hidden, unlisted videos.
And let's not forget the website
that's no longer available.
So go, hunt around,
see what you're able to put together
and make sure you subscribe to them
since you're probably going
to want to be there
when they inevitably do a season
two of this thing.
So let's do what they openly acknowledge
that we do best and give you the gist
of what happened,
what you may have missed along the way,
and then predict
what season two has got in store.
Grab your QR codes and fishing poles
loyal theorists,
because today we're untangling the mystery
of the shorts war ARG.
Let's just start back at the beginning,
how this whole thing kicked off.
The ball got rolling
when Jonny RaZeR posted
a short to his channel that at first
didn't seem all that out of the ordinary.
You got Jonny
telling a story in front of a green screen
with some Minecraft parkour playing around
in the background, classic shorts stuff.
But then the video glitches out,
with the QR code briefly
flashing on screen
before returning to normal.
Scanning the QR code redirects
you to an unlisted video
called Message.mp4 featuring a masked man
with a voice filter.
This ominous bad guy
goes by a lot of different names
across the fan community,
but we're going to be calling him
The Boss for this video.
And right off the bat,
The Boss makes his opinions
about YouTube shorts and specifically
their creators quite clear.
During this villain monologue,
we see eight channels flash up
across the screen: Jonny RaZer, Mogswamp,
RoyalPear, Joe Caine, Danno Cal Drawings,
knsplash, Bundun and Phaleur.
The boss ends up giving these creators
an ultimatum.
They need to stop making shorts
within the next week
or they will be, quote unquote, replaced.
That right there, that is ominous.
Since the ARG started on July 16th,
that meant that they only had
until July 23rd, one week later, to stop.
And as it turns out, two of the creators,
Mogswamp and knsplash actually
took the message to heart.
I will. That was totally a threat.
But since those two complied
with the boss's orders,
they are not part of the story
from that point forward,
at least for this particular season.
This then leaves our main six creators.
And let's just say by the end of that
first week, they were probably wishing
they'd heeded the warnings.
Begun, the shorts wars have.
Over the next week, some oddities
start plaguing the remaining six creators
as their videos roll out.
What kind of oddities
are we talking about?
Well, you'll be watching a Phaleur video
when all of a sudden you see Jonny
RaZeR Gangnam
styling throughout the frame.
In fact, across all the channels,
we start to see these sorts of crossover
glitches.
What's more,
if you look at the actual content
of these videos,
a common theme starts to develop.
All of a sudden,
these creators can't stop talking
about clones, almost like they're worried
about being replaced.
But believe it or not,
that wasn't even the strangest thing
to start happening in the videos.
A bunch of the shorts started
hiding this random string of 11 characters
in their videos, which immediately
got my theorist senses a-tingling.
Normally
this would be where we whip out our Caesar
ciphers or decoder rings,
but here there's no need.
Thanks to working on YouTube longer
than most of the audience
watching it's been alive,
I instantly recognized this as a YouTube
video ID.
So I slapped it into a URL
and was taken to
this unlisted video called Clone_VPN.mp4.
Hmmm, clone.
There's that word again.
Anyway, at first
this doesn't seem so different
from the millions of other ads for VPNs
that you see across YouTube
already.
You get it, we get it.
We've all seen a billion
VPN ad reads at this point.
We also get a list of the Clone
VPN partners,
which features a lot of the people
that were expressly
called out by the boss.
But then we get to this feature right here
that truly sets clone VPN apart.
And let me tell you, we're not talking
about unlocking international streaming
rights
that aren't available in your country.
Clones, disappearing and reappearing,
slight but unnoticeable changes.
Yeah,
the narrative is clearly forming here.
The Boss is going to somehow clone
and replace these YouTube shorts creators
through Clone VPN.
Now the only question is: how?
Well, I'm going to tell you the
how in a minute,
but before that, I can tell you the how
they could have avoided
this threat entirely,
if only the shorts creators had used
the sponsor for today's video: Incogni.
Yeah, step aside there Clone VPN,
we've got a real sponsor in the house.
Tell me if this one sounds familiar.
The other week
I was out at the grocery store
stocking up on a gallon sized jug of Diet
Coke, and I signed up for their loyalty
card to get a discount.
I thought that I could trust the store,
and yet, lo and behold,
I almost immediately started getting all
these spammy emails and scam phone calls.
Another time
I was searching up information
about Mattel for our Barbie video
that we just released.
And now all the ads that I see
everywhere are Amazon links to Hot
Wheels and Ken Dolls.
This happens
because in the United States, it's
totally legal for companies
to track, collect
and sell your personal data
without you knowing anything about it.
And it's not just your email
and shopping habits
that these corporations
are getting a hold of.
It is a lot of your private information
as well, stuff that you do not want
to get out into the public.
We're talking your full name,
your home address, your phone
number, your relatives,
aliases, education, employment, history.
Heck, even your Social Security number.
There is no world where they need to know
any of that stuff.
The good news here
is that you have the right to request
that these data brokers
delete your information.
That way
you can sleep safe and sound at night
knowing that you're not going to get
a random phone call
at midnight trying to sell you
the latest Barbie Malibu Dream Mansion.
The downside to everything though,
it might take you actual real years
to get all your info scrubbed clean.
Incogni though, can help you with that.
While services like VPNs are defensive,
trying to keep your info out of the hands
of these corporations.
Incogni actually goes on the offense.
They're going to be your representative
and track down the brokers
who are actively selling
your personal information out there,
and then they demand that they leave
you alone.
Delete your stuff from the system.
Your personal information
is being bought and sold
and you are getting nothing out of it
except a nuisance.
It's time to change that.
And Incogni is the key to help.
Let me tell you,
after signing up for their service
to test out for myself,
I saw the difference overnight.
Gone were all the obnoxious spam emails
that I was getting
and as far as phone calls
go, I don't get any.
Spam or otherwise.
Which is exactly the way it should be.
If you want to protect your data today,
go to Incogni.com/FilmTheory
and use the code FILMTHEORY
to get 60% off an annual Incogni plan.
Again that's Incogni.com/FilmTheory
and then use the code FILMTHEORY.
Or, you know,
you can just skip all that hassle
and just go down to the top
line of the description.
Thanks again to Incogni
for sponsoring this video
and keeping my personal information
out of the Boss's hands.
And now, let's hop back to the shorts
wars.
See, when you're
dealing with malicious A.I.
or evil VPN program, in order for it
to harm you or your computer,
you need to let it in, so to speak.
Viruses operate on vampire rules.
They have to be invited
in by running a program
or clicking a bad link or something.
Well, that's exactly what all these shorts
creators did.
On July 20th, RoyalPear uploaded a short
with another hidden video ID.
Here we see the shorts creators finding
an email in their inbox from Clone VPN,
reaching out for a sponsorship deal.
They're offered a crisp $20,000
for an ad read
and wanting to secure the bag,
they each click a not so suspicious link.
Nothing can possibly go wrong from that,
right?
Somehow this allows the Boss
to access their computers
and use their online identities
as a base to clone them.
How can we be sure about this?
Well, everyone accepts the clone VPN deal
except for one of them: Joe Caine.
Yep. The Internet's favorite shorts
speed running Swede turns down the deal,
and as you can tell by the text
that flashes across the screen
as he closes the email,
the boss ain't too happy about it,
but the rest of his master
plan is proceeding on schedule.
You see, on July 22nd, the day
before the boss's ultimatum comes due,
I found QR codes hidden in Jonny
RaZeR and Danno’s channels that take us to
an unlisted video that shows us
exactly how the clone sausage gets made.
We find ourselves in some sort
of scientific facility, and one by one,
information about each YouTuber
is uploaded into some strange machine.
The computer powers up
and using all the data
a literal clone of the creators
is generated in the physical world.
It's here that we see
that the boss is true to his word:
both the good and the bad.
Both Mogswamp and knsplash aren't cloned
because they listened to the boss
and stopped making shorts
while the others are cloned, though,
some turn out better than others.
Jonny RaZeR, Phaleur and Bundun's
clones are made without an issue.
But during the cloning process
for RoyalPear,
there's an ERROR R34
that appears on the screen of the machine.
And it's at this point
that the people on team theorist
that aren't familiar
with the rules of the internet
realized that they probably shouldn't
be googling RoyalPear R34.
Masterful troll there guys.
Anyway,
that error causes the clone machine
to create a malformed clone of RoyalPear’s
normal Tropius design.
The final clone to be made in the machine
is Danno’s Channel's character, Riggy.
Interestingly, since the Riggy character
was the one who clicked the sponsorship
link on behalf of Danno the creator, he's
the one who got himself cloned.
However, due to his giant
bunny ears and long monkey tail,
the machine hilariously can't figure out
what species he's meant to be
and the machine partially blows up.
But not before spitting out a strange
looking clone of Riggy,
just without the tail.
As the 23rd rolls around
and the boss's deadline passes,
the clones are deployed
to the various channels
and we see their violent takeover
in some comically over-the-top
yet still YouTube monetization friendly
violence.
Jonny RaZeR's clone shoots
his original seven times in the chest.
Bundun is kidnaped under the table mid video.
While Riggy, Phaleur and RoyalPear’s
clones are taken away to some
unknown fate.
But for all the creators,
the results are the same.
Each of the new clone
creators uploads an ad for Clone VPN,
all of which are basically carbon copies
of the same thing.
It's almost like
they're all clones of each other.
So basically this gives us a glimpse
of what happens when the boss wins.
The clones are just shoveling out
content now.
They're recycling scripts,
they're reusing ideas,
they're copying one another
in an endless loop of video sludge.
What's even worse, though, is that
a new date's being seen in the background
to some of the newly uploaded shorts
pointing to July 30th.
This is the day where
all the original creators will be killed
and the clone invasion will be complete.
So, is that it?
Is all hope lost for these shorts creators
as these half rate clones
come in and just take over the content?
Thankfully, no.
The O.G. creators are fighting back
from the inside.
All through the videos, they leave notes
saying that they're still alive.
With Jonny RaZeR somehow
surviving being shot seven times.
Now he himself is hatching a plan
behind the scenes to get into the facility
and save the day using a special flash
drive that he somehow magically obtained.
How? Don't ask, at least not yet.
But the clock is ticking.
They don't have much time before
July 30th comes to pass,
and many of the creators are killed
for good.
Namely, both RoyalPear
and Riggy are in the most immediate danger
as both are currently being held
in the clone VPN facility.
But they're not going to take it lying
down.
On July 29th,
Danno uploaded a short where clone Riggy
finally goes off the deep end.
A QR code is hidden
at the end of this one,
leading us to a then-unlisted video titled
WhereDidRiggyGo.mp4.
Here we see both Riggy and Pear
being interrogated by their clones.
But Riggy is able to escape,
free Pear and book it towards an exit.
Interestingly, the end card of this one
actually takes us to another video
with audio of a conversation
between clone Riggy and the Boss.
And let's just say that
the boss man is not happy
with RoyalPear and Riggy's escape.
And we learn that the two found
the facility's control room
while exiting the building.
Realizing that they're PNG Tubers
and therefore two dimensional, Riggy
and Pear slip through the door
and they see that the Boss’s plan is way
bigger than they ever realized.
Yep. The boss's big plan
is to use his VPN sponsorship to clone
every short's tuber and replace them
with just garbage content.
And given how widespread VPN sponsorships
are, I’m
guessing he's going to be able
to get every single YouTuber
on the platform in less than a month.
But thankfully, there's a way
to stop his plan once and for all.
If they pull all the codes together and
use the energy to overload the machine,
they can use that power to create a virus
that'll knock out Clone VPN forever.
What then, is the code?
Well, here's where things get really cool.
Remember when all the clones did
those sponsorship videos back
when they first took over?
Well, each video ends with a promo code
that features
2 to 3 characters, their name,
and then a number 1 to 5.
Now, I saw this and knew
it had to mean something.
By removing the creator names
and then ordering
what's left by those numbers at the end.
You get this.
Now surprisingly,
that isn't a YouTube video ID,
even though it's
the same length and format.
So I assumed that
it was some sort of a code or a cipher,
but that also didn't work.
We just didn't
have all the information at the time.
This is what that code is for.
It was yet another masterful troll.
And I've got to admit, this time.
This time they definitely got me.
But there's a problem.
They need someone on the outside
to enter the code.
Thankfully, they remember that
Joe Caine refused the deal and hasn't
been captured.
Scanning the QR code that pops up on
screen sends us to another secret video
where Joe puts the code into the Clone
VPN website,
which lets Riggy and Pear create
the virus, a virus that just so happens
to teleport
into the possession of Jonny RaZeR. Yup.
That's where he got the drive from.
A fact
that the boss realizes in real time.
Though we don't actually see it happen,
RaZeR uploads
the virus, which then allows
each of the creators to have a 1v1 battle
against their clones to regain control
and end this saga once and for all.
With the creators victorious, we’re
treated to a post-credits
scene where the Boss and clone
Riggy vow to come back.
And then it's here
that we get our big twist ending.
The flannel.
Jonny RaZeR was The Boss the entire time.
No, that's not possible.
But, but no, really,
that's literally not possible. Right?
If Jonny was the one
who uploaded the virus
and saved the day,
that means that he played
an integral part in his own plan failing?
Doesn't really make a whole lot of sense.
I mean, sure, maybe you could argue
that Riggy did the smart thing
and went to the server room by himself.
But this post ARG Q&A
stream seems to argue otherwise.
Even if we ignore these non-canon
live streams.
In the logic of the show,
Jonny can't be the big boss.
Remember earlier, when The Boss said this?
It doesn't make sense
why he'd both pretend to hate RaZeR
and then openly admit that he's RaZeR
in the very next scene.
So no,
this man can't be the real Jonny RaZeR.
So is it a clone then?
Jonny's clone is.
Yeah, he's not having the best time.
So if The Boss is neither
the real or clone version of Jonny RaZeR,
then who is he? A third clone? PewDiePie?
Me? This is where I have to wave
the white flag, at least for now.
I don't think there's quite
enough information
out there to solve that mystery
just yet, and I suspect
that The Boss's identity will be revealed
when Shorts War has its season two,
which I, for one, am totally stoked for.
I got to say,
this is got to be one of the coolest ARGs
that I've seen happen across YouTube.
And what's more,
I believe the story that these
creators told has a lot more meaning
than just a bunch of clones taking over.
See, while watching this, I kept coming
back to the question, What's the point?
And I don't mean that in a harsh, like,
‘why do they make this?’ sort of way.
No, I wanted to know what theme they were
trying to communicate through all this.
And I believe that we find that in
the entire concept of this thing, Clones.
The story of this
first season of the Shorts
War is a commentary
on cloned content across the Internet.
I'm sure you've seen these sorts of things
around before.
Either
YouTube channels or Tiktoks or whatever
will just rip content from other websites
and re-upload them trying to make a quick
buck off of someone else's work.
It's a problem that we here at theorist
have to deal with all the time,
and it's something that Jonny
RaZeR himself even talked about before
the Shorts War ARG began.
This, I believe, is
what sparked the whole idea of ARG.
See, the clones that we see in the series
could never truly replace the creators
because they aren't those creators.
Riggy actually
sums it up perfectly in one of his shorts.
Those real world clone Tik Tok accounts
might be able to steal and upload videos,
but they're never going to be
those creators.
A person's work is a culmination
of their own experiences
and insights, their successes
and their failures
all wrapped up into a person
with their own thoughts and feelings.
And in the story,
I think that the clones realize this,
or at least some of them do,
like RoyalPear’s clone.
During one of his shorts,
he seems to have second thoughts
about all the mindless creation of content
that's now his life.
And later, as he's interrogating the real
RoyalPear, the clone feels bad about it.
He's only doing it
because his boss, the algorithm
that needs content, is demanding it.
But here's the thing,
there's another path in all of this.
You can take the content of a creator
that you love and do your own pass.
You can use it as inspiration
to create your own art.
Even if it's similar to the people
who inspired you, it'll be uniquely yours
because you're the one who made it.
And here's the spoiler alert
Nothing is ever wholly original anymore.
I mean, Mozart and Da Vinci didn't
create their own works in a vacuum.
They were inspired by what they enjoyed
looking at and listening to.
Your favorite YouTubers, exactly the same.
Here's Jonny RaZeR's thoughts
before they started the ARG.
Couldn't have said it better myself
Jonny.
I was pretty darn inspired
by all of your collective work.
Onward to season two, my friends. But hey!
That's just a theory. A FILM THEORY!
aaaaaaaand cut.